attention à vous
attention à vous il tourne peut-être
déjà parti si j'étais pas fier de ce que
je faisais on a une responsabilité quand
même entretenir les rues de Paris c'est
pas n'importe quoi mais on est invisible
aux yeux des gens
depuis six heures le corps à corps entre
les éboueurs de quartier et la rue bat
son plein c'est là que tout son débuté
a rejoint Christophe qui est dans le
métier depuis 27 ans tu pousses avec ton
pied on a les bras on a les jambes
vraiment dans une rue dangereuse ouais
tu mets un bac devant toi et un bac
derrière comme ça ça te protège
c'est avec les deux roues c'est la folie
qui s'est fait taper par un scooter il a
pris pleine face alors que les bacs ils
étaient posés
ça dérange pas non tranquille
en fait on a rien à faire là
c'est nous qui genons c'est pas eux
on fait partie du paysage
les gens ils font pas le tri sélectif
ils vont te mettre du vert dans les
badges
complètement les gens eux du moment
qu'ils ont envie de leur poubelles ah tu
peux même trouver maintenant sur le tri
sélectif en plus qui te disent que tu
peux mettre et peut pas mettre
je vous débarrasse merci
bon courage merci beaucoup
surveille les balcons parce que tu en as
quand même il jette tout par le balcon
pour ça des fois je lève la tête oh là
tu me donnes un bon conseil là ouais ça
on n'y pense pas ça regardez la tête en
haut voilà exactement toujours regarder
ce qui se passe au-dessus de ton épaule
et la rue c'est un cendrier géant
[Musique]
on est là pour ramasser bah ouais bah
oui
[Applaudissements]
des belles choses là dans les poubelles
ouais c'est déjà arrivé
un lecteur multimédia Bose
carrément lecteur Bose lecteur Bose DVD
avec la centrale ça fonctionnait ouais
ouais ça fonctionne ça coûte cher dans
le commerce ça ouais j'ai regardé
dernièrement ça coûte encore 200 roubles
[Musique]
et justement
c'est quoi va doucement
klaxon pas doucement
déjà on peut notre maximum et voilà les
plus vite ils ont qu'à passer par dessus
ils ont arrêté de fumer
j'aurais peut-être déjà parti si j'étais
pas fier de ce que je faisais on a une
responsabilité quand même entretenir les
rues de Paris c'est pas n'importe quoi
mais on est invisible aux yeux des gens
quand on collecte quand on bloque une
rue là il nous voyent là ils voient que
on bloque la rue on est visible on nous
pourtant on a des beaux gilets jaunes
fluo avec des blancs des bonnes blondes
bandes réfléchissantes donc là on le
voit bien quand même mais principalement
c'est mon a rien à faire là où malgré
qu'on commence à 6h la réplique que
j'aime bien c'est oui nous on travaille
c'est vrai que nous derrière on s'amuse
on charge en gros ouais je dirais bien 6
tonnes par personne par jour et dans
n'importe quel coin de Paris on va
arriver à un endroit que ça soit un
angle de rue ou une impasse elle sera
sale parce que les gens ne prêtent pas
attention à ce qu'ils font la poubelle
est pleine mais au lieu de de chercher
une autre poubelle non il continue de
jeter à côté à côté et puis là ça senta
ça senta c'est après on dit oui il y a
de plus en plus de rats à Paris pourquoi
parce que les déchets sont à côté des
poubelles donc bien sûr il y a plus de
race qui est tout à fait normal parce
que les gens jettent les gens sont sales
Paris est une poubelle géante
[Musique]
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
Mireille Dumas abonnez-vous et activez
la cloche
[Musique]